dressing the media he'll talk about
healthcare that is set for about 1:30
Eastern we plan to have that live and
now it looks like we do have senator
Sanders thanks very much here with the
senator ben cardin in Maryland who just
wanted to say a few words on one aspect
of this legislation you know in the
midst of the overall health care crisis
in America there's one particular crisis
that Senator Cardin and I and others
have focused on and that is the crisis
in primary health care and that means
that some 60 million Americans today do
not have access to a doctor on a regular
basis and what that ends up meaning is
that when people get sick they end up in
the emergency room or they become sicker
than they should have been and they end
up in the hospital a great personal
suffering and pain and sometimes in
death we have 45,000 Americans every
single year who died because they do not
get to a doctor on a regular basis what
this managers amendment today does is
add 10 billion dollars more over a five
year period into community health
centers in the National Health Service
Corps what that will mean is that an
additional 25 million Americans will now
have access to federally qualified
health centers which means high quality
primary health care dental care low cost
prescription drugs and mental health
counseling
it also means because of a very
significant increase in the National
Health Service Corps we're going to be
forgiving debts incurred by medical
students who go into primary care 20,000
more primary health care physicians and
dentists and nurses will be developed as
a result of the increase money in that
provision so I can tell you that in my
state where in recent years we have
significantly increased community health
centers it has a profound impact on the
health and well-being of our people and
at the end of the day what studies
indicate is Medicaid
Eve's money because we keep people out
of the very expensive emergency health
rooms and we keep them out of hospitals
so this is a win-win proposition we have
ten billion dollars now in the Senate
bill working with our colleague Jim
Clyburn I in the house they've got 14
billion dollars in the house bill we
believe that the final number will
probably be 14 billion and if that
happens there will be a revolution in
primary health care in America 25
million more people having access to
high-quality health care dental care
mental health counseling and low cost
prescription drugs
let me introduce senator Cardin well
first I want to congratulate senator
Sanders for his leadership on this I
have sat through many of the meetings of
our caucus where senator Bernie Sanders
has raised this issue over and over
again and let me try to underscore how
important this is we all know we have a
shortage of primary care health care
professionals we also know we don't have
enough facilities in our community to
handle all of our population who want to
receive health care senator Sanders and
I have been fighting for many many years
for universal health coverage this bill
didn't just want to do a great service
to America and getting a lot more people
in short 31 million is with the
Congressional Budget Office we hope
there will even be more than that the
question is where they're going to get
their health care needs met we don't
have enough primary care physicians
today we don't have enough space in our
clinics I have visited the community
health centers in Maryland they have one
thing in common they all need more
capacity they are already are stretched
in capacity as to what they can handle
we need more locations particularly in
the rural areas where people are having
a hard time finding a primary care help
and we need more capacity generally
throughout our nation I had a chance to
talk to one of the leaders at Johns
Hopkins Hospital in Baltimore who's a
strong proponent of this bill because he
believes that America we should have
universal access
to affordable health insurance but he
told me that if we don't do something to
produce more health care primary care
professionals and if we don't provide
more community health center capacity
that we're not going to be able to
provide the care in the most
cost-effective way the bill that we had
on the floor of the United States Senate
needed to be improved in this area and
senator Sanders has accomplished that
and I know that there's a great deal
focus on on some of the major
controversial issues but our objective
is to make sure every American has
access to affordable health care and
senator Sanders initiative will help 25
million more Americans reach that goal
congratulations senator
any questions can you respond to that
use the term sweetheart you know Vermont
was and I don't have all the details in
front of me Vermont has been very
aggressive in making sure that all of
our low-income kids and others have
access to health care we were there and
doing the right thing and what many of
us in Vermont and around the country
felt that it was wrong to penalize a
state that had done a better job than
perhaps any other side I think
Massachusetts was up there as well you
know penalized States because states on
their own come up with money to do the
right thing and say thank you very much
for taking care of your low-income kids
thank you taking care of more people
percentage-wise than other states and
now we're gonna penalize you for doing
that we did not think that that was
right so that's not a sweetheart deal
that is saying you're not going to
penalize states that I've done the right
thing and we're proud in Vermont that
we've done the right thing but our
taxpayers should not be penalized
because they've done that but the bottom
line here for me on this bill is Senator
Cardin said so well is that it if you
expand Medicaid and if you expand health
insurance in general that is enormous ly
important
but at the end of the day it doesn't
mean much if people can't find a doctor
or they can't find a dentist and what we
have managed to accomplish it's a
substantially increase community health
centers 10,000 communities in America as
a result of this legislation will now
have access through a community health
centers 10,000 more communities 20,000
more primary health care physicians and
dentists and we think that that is going
to help revolutionize primary health
care and American is a really important
step forward in healthcare reform okay
okay thanks very much
independent senator Bernie Nelson along
with Bernie Sanders
I'm sorry along with Maryland senator
ben cardin on health care President
Obama is expected to address the media
on the health care bill today that'll
happen at about 1:30 Eastern and we'll
have live coverage of that here on
c-span and with an apparent agreement on
health care reached in the Senate we'll
go back to earlier today to hear from
senator ben nelson he was the democrats
lone holdout to getting those 60 votes
that they needed to pass the bill here
are his remarks now on his decision this
is